oh I guess while you get your medicine
I'll just stroll to the candy I won't
get any you didn't buy two candies who
can have you I have the flu
super nauseated for a few days a lot of
barfing it's a total disaster plus I
have a ton of work to do so I need the
good stuff the Mariah needs to sing
tonight stuff you don't look flushed no
signs of fever that doesn't seem like
the flu it's the flu I mean I don't
think it could be anything this counts
as one let's say I typed your symptoms
into the thing up here and it says you
could have network connectivity problems
let's do Ron Swanson's office yes I will
transfer you I just dropped another call
oh hey Ron hey shiny shoes you got there
oh hey I was just um I think oh no
actually it looks like I scuff this one
do you need your money back around cuz I
already spent it really how didn't never
mind
uh I think I'll just take another full
polish can I cut in lying again I feel
right at home as a shoeshine I have no
idea what I'm doing but I know I'm doing
it really really well do you remember
anything about a key or April doing
anything unusual that day she did make a
stop by the shoeshine stand before he
left because she wanted to drop
something off for Andy she had a real
bad crush on him Oh baby you had a crush
on me that's embarrassing we're married
yeah you really shouldn't have dug that
out of the dumpster I had to also I had
a banana on the way over here sorry I
get why you don't want anyone to know
about Duke silver and you don't have to
worry
your secret is safe with me to even it
out I'm gonna tell you all of my secrets
oh no that's not necessary
I once forgot to brush my teeth for five
weeks I didn't actually sell my last
card as forgot where I parked it I don't
know who Al Gore is and at this point
I'm too afraid to ask when they say 2%
milk I don't know what the other 98% is
when I was a baby my head was so big
scientists experiments on me I once
threw beer as Swann and then it attacked
my niece Rebecca
that'll do Andrew you don't have to play
the unity concert but don't quit music
please whoa check out the new digs this
place is insane thanks for coming guys
I'm super swamped and I need your help
Pass you came down here to pass on
helping me yeah I wanted to see what
your face look like when I said no it
was totally worth it Andy
you okay I'm fine it's just that life is
pointless and nothing matters and I'm
always tired also I can't sleep I'm
overeating none of my hobbies interests
me ever since Andy failed the police
academy exam his self-esteem has hit
rock bottom
he's always sad and sweaty he's usually
happy and sweaty we're not giving up on
this he's not the only musician in town
Andy yeah I don't know let's see I don't
really feel like playing right now
please please please please please
please
I don't even have children's songs my
last song I wrote was called sex hair
well just take the word sex and change
it to pickle pickle you've got pickle
here baby and you got it from me
it sounds like it's about sex I'm in I
gotta grab my guitar for my house I'll
be back shortly yeah
see guys we have a solution and
there's always a solution if your
motives are pure
[Music]
you have two broken bones in your right
arm and four in your hand that's the
side that hurts how soon until he's
better
well set the fractures I'd like to keep
him overnight for observation
is there any chance you can fix me in
the next ten minutes sure I'll just
advance medical science thirty years
great can mouse rat play without you
they tried once they're called rat and
mouse and they're awful but you have got
to find somebody there's an old saying
show business the show must go wrong
everything always goes wrong and you
just have to deal with it can't believe
we're at Hogwarts no that's Buckingham
Palace Hogwarts is fictional do you know
that it's important to me that you know
that Iran can I ask you kind of an
important question you know like when
you go to the ATM and you get money is
there an actual guy standing behind the
wall who slides dollar bills in there no
yeah this robots Oh actually you know
what I do have a serious question in the
movie predator can you rub any kind of
mud on yourself to prevent predator from
seeing you with his thermal heat
signature site or is it oh that sucks
are you hurt oh no all good all good
oops except for my mouth oh whoa
five-second rule no ah come on
we'd better get you to a dentist
my tea buddy what are we doing we didn't
get a single thing that bent ones - sure
we did we got the marshmallow shooter
axe I think it's on the list
but I want it I want to do but I also
kind of want my own Fork just cuz you
eat really slow which is cute but also
super annoying fine
what what's wrong nothing it's just
adults are boring and I hate them and I
don't want to buy all this stupid boring
adult stuff and become boring adults hey
listen to me
yes we're gonna get a dish rack and
shower curtains and a cutting board but
if you think for one second I'm not also
gonna get that marshmallow shooter so
that I can shoot you in the face with
marshmallows when you're asleep then
you're the dumbest one what I know I'm
gonna make me cry the receptionist
socials fits you in as soon as there's
an opening if you're alright I'm gonna
head back to the park
like what do you know what my social
security numbers or if I'm allergic to
anything
I don't like corn so put that down or
will that be confusing because I do like
candy corn oh what a mess here let me
help you
all I wanted was two hours where I got
to forget that I was a parent oh look I
found all three differences those are
two completely different pictures well
you will not be hiring anyone because my
department is just finishing up a major
project
I think you'll agree that this
department could use a little leadership
and your Hani High prom king and queen
are Lucy Taylor and ND Dwyer what
I broke the box and I threw away all the
votes and I voted for you a thousand
guys you should get on up there Q Dwyer
not without my cool hi Pawnee hi as your
prom king I am your ruler satellites my
first decree of power is to declare that
the prom queen
shall be my wife April Ludgate who is
the best students ever have me who came
to prom even though she hates it give me
this always next year no there isn't
I'm a senior this is your wife how old
are you he's 33 and I'm 47 slash
immortal get out Oh Andy tell me what
happened I was reading an encyclopedia
and I tripped or fell over and hit my
head or brain helmet you'd call it yeah
he sneezed and smacked his head against
the wall that sounds about right
well if it's a concussion it's extremely
mild so I wouldn't worry about it
anything else bothering it nope yeah
well I mean yeah I've got a weird rash
in my knee pit area and my tongue on
this side doesn't taste anything anymore
sometimes when I walk my ankles make
like a weird rattlesnake sound what else
things that are far away from my eyes
are fuzzy I once ate a Twix with the
wrapper on it and I've never seen the
wrapper come out also I've swallowed
every piece of gum that I've chewed for
the past 25 years I don't know broke my
phone when the way over here it just fix
me well I can help you with the thumb I
don't have to give you referrals for
specialists for the other thousand
things
thanks for nothing dr. Harris
you